what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
today we have some amazing
she-hulk news a lot of people have been
very very excited since she-hulk was
announced tatiana monselani of course
is playing she-hulk and it has been
confirmed that mark ruffalo will be
returning as professor hulk in the
series as well which makes a ton of
sense because jennifer walters aka
she-hulk and
bruce banner aka the hulk are cousins so
no surprise there but
ever since she-hulk was announced
everybody has been wondering who
exactly is the villain going to be and
today we have a report from the
illuminerty.com stating that they have
discovered who the villain is
including the actress that is going to
be playing her and maybe you haven't
heard of this villain before but this
villain has a
very very direct connection to dr
doom so hopefully the mcu will kind of
stick true to this character's origin
story of how she gets her powers and
hopefully that means doctor doom will be
in the mcu
very soon so don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
updates
so according to the illuminati.com the
main villain of the she-hulk series
opposite of tatyana man's ladies
jennifer walters is going to be
titania and she's going to be played by
the actress jamila
jamil now if you're pretty familiar with
the secret war storyline
you'll know who tatanya is if you don't
no worries i got you i'll explain but
first let's talk about her role
in the show this is how the upcoming
she-hulk villain is described
according to the illuminati the
description for her is a villain
that is a kardashian-esque social media
influencer in her 30s with a dark side
and this will give a really different
approach
a more modern approach to the character
and to the series which has been
described as
a legal comedy because jennifer walters
is a lawyer
now titania isn't actually the villain's
real name that's her
villain name but in the comics her real
name is mary mcferrin she was born
prematurely so she was very small and
very timid
so throughout her life she would get
picked on and bullied in school because
of this she was super fascinated with
superheroes and imagined herself
gaining powers and not being so scrawny
and weak anymore well she would
eventually get her
wish because she lived in denver
colorado which became a part of the
secret wars
battle world and mary along with her
friend marsha were found by dr
doom himself and dr doom offered the two
powers
using alien technology in exchange for
their help on battle world and they both
agreed her friend marsha became the
villain volcano
and mary gained superhuman strength
stamina and durability and she took on
the name
tatanya which to her meant strength of a
titan she would go on to fight in secret
wars alongside of doctor doom she would
go up against many heroes but most
notably she went up against she-hulk now
this isn't the only time she would go up
against she-hulk she would actually go
up against she-hulk plenty of times and
although titania was somewhat of a
worthy adversary to she-hulk she-hulk
usually beat her titania
even used the power stone or the power
gem as they called it in the comics
against she-hulk and still lost but of
course we know that marvel studios just
doesn't take stories directly from the
comics and put them on screen
they change them up plus we know that
she's not going to be the only villain
of the she-hulk series because it's
already been confirmed that tim roth is
returning as
abomination now right now it's unclear
on whether or not
she hulk is going to be taking on
abomination by herself or if that's why
mark ruffalo's the hulk is coming in
because taking on abomination and to
tanya is going to be something that she
hulk
probably can't do at first so it's great
that she's going to have the help of the
hulk
and side note maybe we'll see the
original hulk come back maybe professor
hulk will be done with and the
incredible hulk can rise again
now to me the most exciting part about
titania
joining the mcu and being one of the
main villains of she-hulk is not only
will it make for good action because
her and she-hulk basically have the same
power superhuman strength stamina and
durability
but it's because of how she gets her
powers that make it so interesting
she gets them from dr doom now she gets
them by him
using alien technology to give her
powers but from him
nonetheless and we know that the
fantastic four is confirmed to be
entering the mcu relatively soon
which means doctor doom should be coming
as well because he is not only a classic
marvel villain but of course a classic
fantastic four villain and if marvel
really is building up to the secret wars
battle world storyline which it really
seems like they are
loki has already introduced the
multiverse in a big way
talking about the multiple different
timelines timelines going to war with
one another
i won't say too much more because i
don't want to spoil loki but we know
that the multiverse is going to be
thrown into madness because that is the
title of doctor strange 2. and of course
this is another huge indication that we
are heading towards a secret war
storyline
and if that is the case then doctor doom
is an extremely
prominent character in that storyline in
fact he goes on to rule battle world and
this is where he becomes god emperor
doom pretty much the strongest version
of doom that we've seen
although i'm sure that could be argued
but one division also set the groundwork
for doctor doom to be set up as well
you see dr doom is one of the most
powerful sorcerers in marvel history
but his mother was also a pretty
powerful sorcerer as well
she was a witch and what did one
division introduce us to
which is actual witches using actual
magic
and who knows maybe in the mcu agatha
harkness would actually know
cynthia von doom who of course is victor
von doom's mother
now in the comics she kind of has a
pretty tragic story
when victor von doom aka doctor doom was
just a young boy cynthia von doom wanted
to help her people who were being
oppressed and attacked so she ended up
making a deal with the demon
mephisto and no i don't think he is
coming in loki i don't think he's coming
in she-hulk i don't think mephisto will
be here soon but i do think he'll show
up eventually but this is just a comic
storyline but mephisto ends up
actually kind of tricking her and she
ends up getting killed and she ends up
getting trapped inside of the hell realm
doctor doom grows up learning sorcery
becoming extremely good and powerful at
it and he goes to fight mephisto to try
and get his mother back
he does this several times but he always
fails until one time he gets the help of
none other than dr
steven strange the two of them travel to
the hell realm together and they end up
tricking mephisto in a way
that allows victor von doom's mother not
to go back to the earthly plane
but she is able to get out of the hell
realm where she was being tortured by
mephisto
and in this other realm she is able to
speak to her son to this day in the
comics to my knowledge she is still in
that realm but you can see
all of the different connections here
one of the main villains of she-hulk has
now been revealed to be titania and
tetonia got her powers from doctor doom
doctor doom's mother cynthia von doom
was a witch one division
introduced witches and agatha harkness
who is a very very
ancient witch and she's still around
even though she's under a spell but she
could perhaps know cynthia von doom
and the way they kind of left it at the
end of one division leads me to believe
that we are definitely going to be
getting more of agatha harkness
so the witches could connect there and
then in the loki series and of course
multiverse of madness it seems like the
multiverse is going to be having some
problems and this definitely looks like
it's paving the way for secret wars
which again dr
doom is a very prominent character in so
hopefully with this casting announcement
and character introduction in she-hulk
that means that doctor doom is not too
far around the corner and i would love
to see doctor doom and the secret war
story line take place in the mcu i've
stated it plenty of times including in
my video earlier on today
i believe that if the mcu truly does do
a secret wars it'll be bigger than
avengers end game
but so far the cast for the upcoming
she-hulk disney plush show is looking
pretty dang good and the characters are
shaping out pretty nicely as well
she hulk the regular hulk or i should
say professor hulk
abomination making his return and now we
have to tanya we're gonna have a pretty
good clash here when
her and she-hulk go at it so let me know
what you think about this news down
below and let me know what you think
about jamila jamil
being cast as to tanya let me know down
below don't forget to subscribe and hit
that notification bell so you don't miss
out on any of the latest mcu videos
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof